while we ring in 2022 on the strip
they'll be celebrating more like it's
1999
downtown jaycee fernandez joins us now
with more on the awesome celebration
expected on fremont street tomorrow
night
the countdown to new year's eve 2022 is
going to be epic right here on fremont
street because we've got a totally
awesome 80s and 90s dance party
celebration happening here to tell us
all about it is andrew simon the ceo
happy new year happy new year too let's
talk about the entertainment because we
have the village people kicking off
tonight this is going to be amazing one
of my favorite fans you can't dance to a
better band than the village people how
about a flock of seagulls one of the
most iconic bands of the 80s they'll be
here tomorrow night biggest terra band
around
tone loca is going to be here yeah tone
look funky called media wild thing and
then we've got bobby brown tomorrow
night i know my prerogative and all the
other hits and probably in the mall
bring it in the new year vanilla ice i
know the mayor and i will be counting
down ice size babies that's going to be
ringing in the new year right here on
fremont street you want people to dress
up tomorrow night right if they can if
you got your 80s and 90s dance wear this
is the place to wear it where else are
you gonna pull it out then on new year's
eve on fremont street now one of the
most iconic movies of the 80s is back to
the future and i found marty mcfly
hanging out here on fremont street how
awesome is this outfit his name is todd
and you're ready to go tomorrow night
huh buddy i can't wait look at the head
to toe he's got the whole look dialed in
and that's what we want and when you're
down here on fremont street tomorrow
night do you need to look up right you
do we're gonna have non-stop
entertainment from your favorite toys to
your favorite movies non-stop things
going up around we're gonna have
acrobats people moving around on stilts
everything's gonna be happening all
around you it is a total party the party
is happening here on fremont street you
can watch it tomorrow night right there
on your tv or if you're in las vegas you
can come join us happy new year from
andrew marty mcfly and myself we'll send
it back to you guys in the studio